what is the square root of 55 now we
know that 55 is not a perfect square
which means the answer will not be an
integer in many exams we are not allowed
to use a calculator what's the solution
then the best way to go about it is
approximation all we need to do is think
of the two perfect squares 55 lies
between it lies between 49 which is 7
squared and 64 which is 8 squared that
gives us a big big hint route 55 lies
between route 49 and route 64 it lies
between 7 and 8 but that's not enough
what do we do now maybe we can find out
how far 55 is from 49 relative to how
fast 64 is from 49 to know how fast 64
is from 49 we find the difference
between 64 and 49 that equals 15 and to
know how far 55 is from 49 we find the
difference between 55 and 49 that is 6
now 6 over 15 will tell us how far the
answer is from 7 6 over 15 is 2 over 5
which is 0.4 so root 55 will
approximately equal 7 point 4 first we
found out the perfect squares 55 lies
between then we found out how far 55 is
from 49 relative to how far 64 is from
49 if you use the calculator you would
get the value as 7.4 1/6 which is very
close to 7 point 4 ok good now try
finding the square root of 210 in the
same way
route 210 lies between Route 196 and
route 225 196 is 14 squared and 225 is
15 squared route 210 lies between 14 and
15 now we just need to find out two
things how far 225 and 210 are from 196
225 minus 196 gives us 29 and 210 minus
196 gives us 14 14 over 29 is what we
are interested in 14 over 28 would be
exactly half as the denominator is
slightly higher than 28 this fraction
would be slightly lesser than half close
to 0.48 or 0.49 we can say that route
210 will approximately equal 14 point 4
8